thank you very much
for inviting me and for the kind
introduction
to all the people home this is not my
Apple computer right I just have to
stress the assignments Institute forced
me to use an Apple device
um
my laptop didn't work and I'm sure it
was not a part of my laptop um
so this is Joint work with Krista
nickenmaier
with application was just received by
the embassy so he's not here
and so I'm talking about various topics
testing membership and algebraic
varieties which you could think of Ideal
proof systems in some sense uh algebraic
natural proofs and also some light
connections to geometric complexity
Theory but I'm trying to keep this at a
rather high level because this is a
quiet mixed uh crowd here so at least
everybody should take something away
from this talk
okay so so natural proofs um
that's just the concept of natural
proofs which goes back to roxboros and
who they care some uh explanation
why we are so bad at making progress and
improving uh circuit lower bounds
and um the advantages this concept of of
natural proof or natural property which
are somehow distilled out of the known
proofs at this time and trying to
describe uh why you could not make a
progress so essentially you have three
properties you have a property p and you
call it Naturals if these three
properties here are fully filled so it
should be useful
in the sense that polyci circuits
functions computed by policy circuit
should have this property because you
want to prove a polynomial a circuit
super polynomial circuit lower bound so
if property should process before field
for all this uh these functions you want
this constructivity
maybe you don't want it but proofs
typically uh
if this constructivity uh property and
then when I give you the truth table of
this function then you can decide
whether the the function gives them um
why does truth table has this property
in size which is pretty normal in the
size of the truth table not in size of
the input and you have this largest
condition that because random functions
typically don't have uh poly size small
circuits um
the random function should have this
property but this year that's important
would expect
should have this uh property uh with at
least one of our poly probabilities
and um essentially I studied non-dual
account proof at the time and they came
up at all the lower bounds proof at this
time or almost all of them they did a
set of statistic properties
and then um
they essentially proof that uh it's a
very short paper but a very fundamental
one they essentially showed that when
you can use this property this natural
property to distinguish pseudo-random
functions
uh from uh that have polyester circuit
from a truly random one
then if you believe in public heat
cryptography uh then this would at least
at least some worship public key
cryptography then uh natural proof
essentially uh breaks this uh
public key cryptography so no natural
proof
will show super polynomials I could tell
about
and if all the proof techniques that we
know have this uh this unnatural then we
are somehow doomed so you have to um
come up with some
uh with some
proof technique that uh
at least one of these three uh one of
these three properties cannot be
satisfied
most likely it should not be usefulness
right because they want to put the super
polynomials
circular bond which would be one of
these two other properties
and um
we also um
maybe not as bad as in the Boolean uh
regime so I can claim that because I'm
from the algebraic regime improving
lower bounds in the algebraic world so
maybe a little bit a little bit better
there and um but still right so we
didn't separate VP from VMP and we have
don't have any super polynomial lower
Bound for
from some explicit polynomial and you
can ask why is this the case
and um this led led to the concept of
algebraic natural proofs which were
defined by Forbes worker and Folk
and in parallel also by Grosso kumas
accents enough
so the first paper made it into into
stock the other one was just the
technical report so that's that's life
but essentially they're both
they both developed at the same time and
essentially they had the the same
definitions were in there and the same
conclusions maybe the only difference is
that fox will can first looked at more
examples but this works very the only
difference
okay and um so what's now our setup
so essentially we have some class of uh
of
um of polynomials
let's call it uh
let's call it C and C is uh just uh
contained in linear span of someone only
so we take a bunch of monomials in the
easiest case say you take all the
monomials and N variables of degree at
mostly other system maybe the more the
most that's the case we are typically
interested in
and then we have a class of polynomials
which is contained in this linear span
of his monomials
and um
now we have a second class of
polynomials let's call it now d
and D is now essentially you should
think of this being a polynomial in the
coefficients
um
polynomial Business Class C here so this
is in some sense something which was the
truth table in the Roxborough uh results
polynomials from this class D here
and then the definition for a polynomial
d
is an algebraic
script be natural proof against this
class C
if the following two uh
the properties are true so D is the
non-zero polynomial
and for all F in my class C D vanishes
on the coefficient factors of f
essentially now you can use this
polynomial D it somehow gives you this
is essentially the property P that we
have
from Adventures on all these functions
or F so all these functions that have
the property and because these now a
non-zero polynomial can use it to
to find a polynomial on which he does
not vanish
if you take this this one D it will
Define the the zero that defines the
hyper surface so it's a variety so
essentially when our letter will be
interested in in finding points f that
don't that are not in the Cyber surface
and um also um
set up and you have these three
properties a usefulness this would be
the same as Vanishing on all the
coefficient factors of C
we have this conceptivity we'll come to
that and you have this largest
condensation right a random function
should satisfy a
guess property and this comes for free
in the algebraic setting at least so I'm
typically interested in infinite Fields
maybe even algebraically closed
and so on then the largest comes for
free because lying outside almost all of
the points they are outside of D so this
hyper surface defines as a risky closed
closed term set and this has smaller
Dimensions or almost all the points uh
lie outside uh in particular
[Music]
um
yeah we know a random polynomial is hard
but uh depressed with someone to come
with an explicit one yeah there's of
course this this constructivity of
course questions of course now how hard
is it to check with a d of fsco
I mean this is azure black World
checking where the D of f is new or it
could mean two things right so I give
you in just a description of f i do
whether it's you simply decide this
questionnaire with a turing machine but
you could also think of this you have a
circuit for D yeah and then you could
think about the circuit size
this could be different things right so
talking about the circuit size of D or
just somehow checking this this property
D of fsco uh this could be could be
different and this could make this year
maybe more more tractable in some sense
nope
and um then
editing set
um
or some class of polynomials p as I have
now a subset of polynomial is p and new
variables
then hitting set is just some bunch of
points
such that for every polynomial p
in my method of polynomials they'll find
the point in my heading set such a p of
H graph that's uh
is that
and now to State essentially the barrier
result of
[Music]
this in this algebraic natural proof
business we need this notion of what is
called a succinct hitting set yeah we
let us see on uh that there are very
there can be very simple hitting sets
but you somehow you won't have a
succinct representation
the succinct hitting set
is again I have my set of monomials and
I have my Class C which is contained the
linear span of this one polynomials and
they have my my polynomial d
and then this set H is called a c set
thing tilling set
for my class D
if
H is contained
in C so my a is first thing of H being
uh we can think of thing being
polynomial so I can think of things
being points by looking at the
coefficient vectors
and then um if I view H as a set of
vectors of coefficients of length M then
this set should be a hitting set for my
uh my class D okay so my
for Class C here
of polynomials I look at all the
coefficient vectors and if they Define a
hitting set for D then um this is called
the C-section feeding set for d
and now the natural proof barrier that
was formulated in these two papers uh is
the following and this is a it's a
theorem but it's essentially almost
immediate from the definitions but of
course it's uh the the point is coming
up right so getting the definitions
right to either do to um to come up with
the theorem here right so if I have now
my Class C again and I have my class of
polynomials I have my class approves d
and then essentially in theorem says
there are no their algebraic denatural
proofs against my Class C if and only if
there are no c-sexting hitting sets for
these and that's essentially obvious
because um
being an algebraic proof means you
vanish on C but being a hitting set
means
for every polynomial indeed there's a
point and see where it does not vanish
right so therefore that's the proof of
the of the CRM and uh
as I said
the hot part is coming up with this do
this definition the definitions right
yeah so in what sense is this a barrier
in that is there any reason to believe
that cesa Saint hitting Seth Brady
exists under certain circumstances so
just it's like that's uh yes that's a
good question where I come to that on
the on the next slide essentially the
same happens so we look at all the
proofs that have been done so far for
the law of uncles and they're all
produced a succinctive effects yeah so
but
but then there's the other side where
you say if there's a one-way function
then there is no natural property is
there anything like that where under
some believe widely believed assumption
there's no uh formulation of some random
functions
all right so therefore it's uh it's
stated here right so you could now say
this is a better conjecture it's a wish
or it's a fear depending on what you
what you want right and whether you want
to have small getting sets or whether
you want to prove circular about that's
one of these three things there are no
um there are Smalls
that's against the polynomial so this is
a
essentially that uh for most non-proof
methods they are natural at that time so
they look at all the robots like in the
not for hooded paper and all of them
essentially uh
exhibited small uh
but there's no this is some remember
this is Major point where there's maybe
more but I have no no shopping
so
um
could you say something about the
difficulty of formulating prfgs
[Music]
I don't
why why aren't there sitter random
functions in the alphabet so what would
be your random function
so what is the random polynomial
the first question
enter
and then essentially
um you have uh well you can of course
say you you fix the the input that would
be a Boolean Cube but that's actually
you
just makes the question you know
sometimes bright one anymore another
pure Edge right of course if you just
want to say I want to have a bunch of
polynomial a one-half polynomials
that's of course that's it yeah sure but
if you know simply have a polynomial um
what does it mean
and then to the reference
yeah
the function in domain again right but
so infinite Fields algebraic blocks
fields
in terms of like uh when C is like let's
say d period or something
um is it clear like non-constructively
that there is a natural property that
has like low degree like maybe not yes
yeah that's a very good question
um you're talking often right yes
right so now that is a typical remember
you have environmental substitute
and um
that you want to look at say poly MD
that's the most general or the setting
you want to look at at Poly size
circuits and then they are essentially
then there is a
an algebraic program and capital N which
is just as the binomic coefficient which
is just the dimension of the
Class C natural proof you can see if
there's no uh succinct heading sets and
uh yeah this is uh
they also want to make
what you of course have here you have
this this exponential gap between the
thickness of The Hitting sets and
between the the size of the of the
surface
setting you can also
do different things so you could even
look uh it makes sense to look at
regimes where you just have a polynomial
Gap you between the class C
and you know your proofs right and for
instance so temporary
is such an example
we have
the cancer T is just some object living
in a in a three it's just a three uh
three-dimensional array of numbers which
includes of a generalization of matrices
we just add one dimension
and then you can also Define the event
one tens of like you can Define rank or
one matrices just the only differences
now you essentially take three vectors
um kind of stay uh in a 3D ambient
spaces and uh adjust in the
just take the the point-wise products of
the of the entry set that you get the
entry in the corresponding uh uh
position of the array and then the rank
of the terms of T is the smallest number
of like one canvas so that you can write
t as the sum of defects
very natural notion you have a
complicated object and you want to
constructed from simple marks
and then Sr will denote a set of
alternators of rank at most r
of course I'm not talking about tensors
but you can also think of the tensor
just being a trial in their form right
where you just uh take um this thing as
the coefficient of xh times x i times
times y i times that J or something
so we're just still talking about
polynomials also or very simple
polynomials the trial in a forms or so I
will just talk about tools
then you can say for instance so DD is
just a poly size natural proof against
my class Sr
if B is non-zero D vanishes on this
class Sr and these computed by a
polyester circuit and now we
understanding yeah so we just have a
polynomial difference so this is just a
cubic number of variables more than the
um
so of course also show some of the
problem so the good news is for example
rank is a hard problem for deciding
whether a tensor has rank are that's NP
hard to decide it's even harder so it's
hard for the existential theory of the
of the possible it's equivalent to the
existential Theory over the
corresponding field
that's good because they somehow could
evade constructivity right right because
now we it's it's harder they could not
they cannot be a polynomial size of it
or some algorithm polynomial time
algorithm
but also some bad news right so I want
to prove that some tensor doesn't matter
the zero set of it's not a variety so
it's not a zero set of a set of
polynomials
but my proofs they are algebraic so they
are given by polynomials and if they
vanish on on SR they will also manage
off the closure of the set of f
which you could think of the the risky
closure or essentially just take all the
points um
let's say think about over the complex
numbers you can either say it's just the
smallest variety that containers are or
you can simply also take just the up
enclosure
equivalent over the complex numbers
and this class let's call it XR and this
is now our variety and this is what is
the so-called border right so this is uh
describes all the tenders that you can
approximate
arbitravily by tensors of rank hours
this is not a virtual problem anymore
because now XR contains containers which
have ranked
which have ranked rated enough at least
for someone almost
therefore um you cannot expect
prove to prove that the rank is greater
than R we can only do it for the
borderline
actually so at least we don't know
whether
roller rank so I I would say we all
think the Border rank is deciding
whether the bordering is pointed by R
but if I think this is it's our problem
but I'm not able uh to prove that and I
think it's still unknown about this
knowledge sure so this is a problem so
what could study is um Can the water
rank is different
foreign
just asked if you look at this
definition right you can just ask do
they exist F1 S3s sorry is it bordering
thanks
for the rank I think we need one
qualifier more because you need a
universal qualifier to uh uh to state
that you are dense in the uh in the
sentence foreign
[Music]
you can also state it uh if you have
stable in defined definition where you
might get a normal Stepside on and then
you can also increase the potentially
yeah
okay and essentially now what we are
interested in want to check
so this is the somehow the question that
we that we have to deal with
let's say Boulder right
because natural proof is like the effect
was lower bounds against some model or
yes so so what what kind of the lower
runs I mean essentially I want to have
some explosives
[Music]
where you can write on the proficiency
is
in there
so the best and the best uh you know the
robots Etc there are some facts for me
and it's really a minus as well so this
is uh
some of the three ambient spaces that's
the uh
even if you two two three plus Epsilon
times and it will already be
this
is foreign
[Music]
I want to keep
because activity so all the proper keys
that you are checking against there
should be somehow
is Center rank useful against some
circuit boards
I guess I'm interpreting the questions
yes
what sort of gaps do they know
um
the problems of course you need to put
the law about right so on the camera
which is already limited on our weather
knowledge I think you can come up with
family I would have a Denver rank almost
3M
at the border exam
which is optimal given a message that we
uh
somehow I mean yeah so what you study is
the right membership so given somewhere
I can win at some point actually I'm in
space decided
uh
modular radical this is essentially a
lot of like an ideal proof system right
because you are want to check uh
yeah I want to check given a point where
it's in the right yeah and what is the
complexity of this problem and somehow
the answers that somehow depends on the
encoding of my variety
for instance if my arrival my variety is
given um as a list of arithmetic
circuits
um
then the membership problem is in corep
because it can just take the circuits
the computer
the questions of my variety
and then I simply check whether all of
them are zero and I can simply use PRT
for that so if not right variety is
given by arithmetry sockets then uh this
is
to
um
or
to give varieties but maybe before I
just want to briefly mention um
for coming sometimes up with some so we
have to succeed at inset so coming up
with some hitting service sometimes easy
yeah because
um
um I can always give you a point where
polynomial gets non-zero if I have to
circuit if it's given by a circuit like
before I can always construct a point
such that if my polynomial
um vanishes on
this point then it's a zero point number
one for instance it has just some
circuit could compute some polynomial
and then if you take this point here
it's a huge point but if f is non-zero
it will not vanish on this this point
which you can prove either by I think it
should be impossible to prove this by
induction otherwise there are some
bounds like I mean your bound or this is
from uh you know polynomial root of
universal polynomials which essentially
tell you that the polynomial cannot
vanish there because some some I just
transform this polynomial into a
univariate one and then I just put in
some point which is so big that it pin
number we cannot vanish yeah that's
that's really good
coming up with some hitting sense it's
easy in this case so it's just a one
point hitting set
just checking this here I just that's
not so easy right so
we need to get Randomness to do this
because we want to compute maybe modular
random Prime
foreign
ways to specify varieties so you could
explicitly encode it into the problem
which you say the border so you would
just say the borders have the right
problem now that's an explicit encoding
I give you a chance I'll give you a
number is the water rank or bounded by r
or not then here's an interesting one
already used half an hour you could um
you can specify a varieties by orbit
closures
so um
we will see some examples in the first
slide so I have some group which acts on
my ambient space
an essence you simply want to know
whether my point the given point V or
whatever a given point x lies in the
the closure of when I let GN acting on
my point of view
that is called the orbit containment
problem orbit closure containment
problem and many problems interesting
problems can be formulated as an orbit
closure problem
you can formulate it as an uh
orbit closure problem
the at least some question of the VP
versus real key problem you can specify
there's an orbit closure problem or
hobby containment problem
and there's a third way and this is
something has something some
when actually reading set to put uh give
a variety by then substance so I have
some circuits then you find me some
polynomial map
where just a bunch of polynomials so
just a bunch of polynomials mapping
points to points but just in each
polynomial for one coordinator plug in
the point and then I look at the image
of this this polynomial map and this
should lie dance and so I can take the
closure of this this point set then I
have a dense and then essentially it can
efficiently generated and subset of
variety and this you could think of as
being some kind of fitting set
if you run a board
of all points which is which is our
infinitely many um
it's uncensely Define hitting
you apply the mapping on the left hand
side you put in plug in all the points
so
which are infinitely many but I'm from
algebra I'm not afraid of infinity many
points um and um then you just get a
look at the image that you get and you
take the smallest variety containing
this this set
closure
and for instance you can Define tensor
rank or border saw you in terms of rank
and Border tends the rank
in in this this language
so um
just like linear maps on my Ambience
basis and
essentially I whenever I have a rank one
hand drawer I just let the first a act
on the first Vector B on the second
vector and C on the sub vector and this
gives me some
[Music]
um
just on arbitrary candles I do this by
linear continuation and then I say it
tensor T Prime is a restriction of t
if there are such a b and c such that
you can write T Prime as uh as a
restriction of t as applying these three
homomorphisms to T and then you can
watch from the definition if you can t
Prime as the Restriction of t
in somewhere here
and also the rank of P Prime is bounded
by the rank of T because this this thing
here takes a rank one tends us to rank
one tensors and if you take the
decomposition of T then you get from
this a decomposition of D Prime
particular that's what it's called the
diagonal times are so you just take the
it's the terms of the big a big Cube and
you just take from the one corner to the
other corner you just take a die in the
middle of one so you can think this of
the generalization of identity Matrix
then you can prove
but Iraq is bounded by our given only
FPS restriction of this diagonal tensor
so the diagonal tensor is in a bigger
space though so it's nice and effective
in a slightly bigger space so you and U
Prime there could be different spaces
but then in the end I simply want to
identify U Prime as a Subspace of U to
be
again in this place yes
and now essentially I can
take all these animorphins now now I'm
identifying U Prime again with u that
that's that's here and we Prime with
three and so on and now I can
essentially take the anomorphisms of
these spaces and I can let act them on
uh on on like one changes by this and
then by linear continuation and then
essentially
the rank of attendance was founded by R
if and only if
It's contained in this this orbit of the
diagonal cancer where led to act the
anamorphism triple animal fifth monoid
onto it
well this is this
says nothing but T is a restriction of R
it's just Rewritten in a in a more fancy
language
but uh this is why this looks nice so
from a medical point of view this is not
nice because this is not uh it's not a
group under composition because there
are no invoices this is essentially why
we um
also you want to switch to water rank
so you can now in replace if you will
use a water rank you can replace this uh
anomorphisms by invertible linear map so
by glr so GL are just all the uh across
eye whatever matrices
and then you can reformulate uh
result on a previous slide for Border
rank just that the Border rank of a
gender t-sponder there are if not only
if G is contained in this orbital here
we can formulate the borderline problem
as an orbit closure process
are there many other ways how to
formulate interesting problems as orbit
closure problems
so there's this disclaimer by Valiant
that whenever we have a polynomial which
can be computed by a formula of size s
or even ABP or size s
uh maybe it's
then there is uh some Matrix pencils or
just some affine linear
so you could single piece so these are
now matrices with a field element of
coefficient Theta variables you could
also think of this being a matrix with
uh F and linear forms after FD entries
and then as we F can be written as the
determinant of such a matrix a and the
size of the matrices is linear in the
size of the formula size or ABCs
then you can Define find some other
action I don't want to
go too much into the details but what
you can show is essentially that um
when you have some group which acts on
some Vector space then the null cone
uh all vectors we such that the zero
point is contained in the orbit closure
of this point e
and um of course this is here of course
right so deciding whether this
determinant here is non-zero or not it
would be identity testing for S right
because uh so whether this has full rank
or not this is a uh identity testing for
apps and we don't know how to do this
yeah but now you can switch to the
non-communitive case so there's also
some non-commoditive version of the rank
of a matrix pencil which I don't want to
Define here
um and then you can show that um
a does not have full non-combative rank
if and only if
[Music]
a is the null cone of some left right
action
um Ace in an icon or under some certain
action here right and the section of
this quite easy maybe I should also just
explain this just take um all these
slices here and then slm which are just
all the matrices will be determined one
and they're just act by by Left Right
conjugation on all these crystallizes
and then you can show that under this
action
um a does not have full non-compositive
rank if not only if a is an icon of this
action so that zero is contained uh in
this orbit here
this is a famous result by by God
Corbett Olivia that this Nikon problem
can be solved statistically in
polynomial time
so for non-commutive rank we have
polynomial time algorithms
and so for Border rank we expect the
problem to be hard but the orbit
problems they are somehow fundamentally
different because for the um
for the tensor rank problem
if you're fixed and this will be my
input yeah so it's on the left hand side
and for an outcome problem
this one here is fixed and this
essentially is my input right so the
points are flying fundamentally
different and this is the reason why
maybe one of the reasons that this
problem here is also different action
and so on but this is a fundamental
difference and of course view is also a
very easy point right so this is maybe
one of the easiest points that you can
think of
is it just
illustration questions
I
so here I want to do just recycle that
in a cognitive case I want to Define
disciples
whether this pencil has full Rainbow
Lodge which is identity testing for S if
a is
[Music]
foreign
approach
and also you can also write
uh Department was a Development question
as all the problems so uh
so running a little bit of time so in
this week you have a free empty business
so the other reductions the essentially
projections we have a trinomial you can
replace all developments by other
variables or by a constant this is very
deep but it was official simply for for
Valium to do his theory so so therefore
I choose this one here
now essentially now we have a polynomial
FN of polynomials and we have some
polynomial GM and whenever I say p
family it means that the decrease
polynominally bounded in the number of
elements quite normally bounded we say
that um what is the projection of the
other one if I can write F and get it
out of G by just checking the projection
of something which is just polynomically
further in the sequence
then you can also back let act the
anamorphism monoid act on my polynomials
sent it because of homogeneity
and this means that in in this setting
if we're talking about homogeneous
polynomials like a determinant you would
have to do add some some padding sector
to make a app up for the degree but then
if we can also
get some algebraic
version of valence conjecture
maybe a weekly definitely to VMP
um there's something weaker and this
essentially you can uh so we ask them
for weekly Q the summer restricted
circuit okay this is equivalent whether
um the permanent is not a p projection
of the determinant
and this you can also formulate as a as
a
only closer problem essentially now that
GL and square actually determinant and
then you want to know whether the padded
permanent is contained in this orbit
closure
this is
such a vnp is not contained in the in
the closure of VP with execute
this is essentially if this observation
is essentially the starting point of
geometric complexity Theory
where essentially you want to um
or essentially want to disproof this
thing here by now using uh
methods from representation Theory and
so on now because we're now dealing with
hard problems and somehow you have to to
also use some some hard machinery
as whatever you want to understand that
there was these fundamentally questions
you won't understand the complexity of
the problem this orbital
and here just one for the last couple of
minutes to focus on tensors
so turn the rank and be hard
it's called the Min rank where
essentially you just look at the slices
of this tensor so you can think of this
thing and matrices and you just ask what
is the smallest non-zero uh linear
combination what's the rank of the
smallest rank of a non-zero linear
combination that you can achieve yeah
and this one uh is also NP hard and for
this one the Border Min Rank and the Min
rank that coincide so there we have one
particular rank measure on on 10 verse
which is nice in the sense that also the
boiler variant is NPR it's not like
slice random slice rack so essentially
if you think of the terms of being n n
matrices
and you just take a linear combination
of this a non-zero one and the question
is what's the minimum rate that you can
achieve and by some compactness argument
of the
um because it's projective
the minimum is essentially attained on
the closure
not in the closure so in the set itself
[Music]
dependable
so this is uh so this is essentially the
Jammer setup
um so we have a sequence of varieties we
have a sequence of points these
varieties might be given by by
um
by uh
by orbit closures and we want to push
that X is not in v by reciprocating some
uh sequence of polynomials that vanishes
doesn't match on the point but it
mentions on the variety
and this FN is essentially this this
natural proof that we had in the
beginning
and we want to understand what's the
complexity of FM because most likely
will be super polynomial if this
membership testing is hard and if you
want to rate this disconfactivity
essentially here's uh it's actually two
more definitions so we say a variable T
is polynomial definable
if you can describe it by a polynomial
set
of equations
that are all polynomically bounded
but this you should think of this being
the proof that you are in the variety
and we say it's uniformly generated
if you can generate a dense subset of a
variety
um
or with polynomial size circuits so you
have to point on my map which this is
described upon your massage circuit and
you uh
can do this uniformly
and what you then can prove is
that uh essentially whenever you have
also some conditions on the feed
whenever you have such a sequence of
varieties that's polynomial definable
and you can uniformly generate a stand
subset then testing beam membership
problems empty heart and the real
membership problems at the heart then
this means uh the co-emp is a sequence
as contained in there is VPP so in
particular the polynomial hierarchy
collapses
eventually you can do this by
essentially you're guessing a circuit so
you're guessing the proof and then
because you know because this will
arrival people are normally refinable
this proof is polynomial
and compute polynomials which generate
uh the stand subset then you can use
polynomial identity testing because you
have this PPP to check whether our
circuit uh again is identically zero on
the on the sub understand subset and
then it also has to mention a whole
variety
and otherwise because now my real
membership is empty heart
you can take some reduction of your
whatever status ability to this problem
so you get some point
and you want to check whether it's the
circuit now vanishes on isn't a variety
and you can now do this by uh take
identity testing polymer identity test
in this way you have now reduced an NPR
problem to some algorithm here which is
uh
because membership testing is the yes
instances they are outside
and let me
the Main Ingredients essentially we have
seen here is the this polynomial
definability which essentially gives you
the Assumption or some lower bound
and you have to
uniformly generated you could think of
this thing it's a little bit stronger
than hitting a generator but it's
typically achieved for instance easy to
achieve for tensors yeah so for instance
uh
or tensors of rank R you can simply take
a sum of our generic running one canvas
this will essentially generate USR
individual proof and this has some
somehow related to the minimum circuit
size problem right so what if uh so what
is the smallest tensor that generates my
trial linear form this is some version
of optimum circuit
but if you have to do this is empty
heart you have to for 10 years
we know that 10 the rank you can it's
uniformly generated then the only
conclusion if you believe that pH is
infinite means that you cannot describe
the variety of tens of ordering R by a
polynomial set of equations that are
five or polynomials
already a little bit over time
let me briefly also have to skip a
little bit of conclude so for um for for
the mid rank everything works for
bordering we don't know whether it's
npreneur
then of course you can ask
can you still prove lower bounds
but other methods to prove lower bounds
for for certain tenders there
and so this is then essentially where
gcp starts
and we can construct essentially various
equations for mini regular IPS using gcp
methods even in the regime where the
membership problems can be hard
but then of course the problem is you
need to prove that the instances that
you get out of this NPR is proof they
don't when uh they're the equations that
the Constructor don't have to vanish and
that's the hard problem so you can
describe them succinctly by some
succinctly represented excellent Society
determinants some succinctly represented
exponential summons or some
representations theoretic objects like
chronic occupations and the stuff
but which I've been studied since 150
years yeah yeah but then you go to a
mathematician who's studying this this
object for 150 years and you just tell
them here's my object here's my point
does it Venture on this and he says how
shall I know this right so we we're only
looking besides with 450 years of this
problem that's way too
way to advance to solve this yeah
so the option is so GCT gives you
methods to come up with small sized
objects that could be approved yeah but
this proves they're incredibly powerful
magicians don't know whether this thing
is zero or not yet so uh
so it's um
yeah so it's it's not only about the
size of your description but also
essentially on how efficient are you
able to evaluate this right it's like in
the end it's like you could also have a
small size for permanent if you have a
permanent gate right so this is
essentially
um the same problem that we're facing
here and the only uh
essentially it's a hard problem right so
and that's it thank you
[Applause]
is
there yeah but that's because
it's very hard to understand these
problems right so this is a it's a super
complicated object and
and then
the non-bordering what you people can
understand because it's it's still
natural object but it's defined pretty
completely right so it's there's a
vector of a chapter linear combination
has
one in terms of such a thumb is the
object and um this you can understand
but then if you take the closure of this
sure
it is very good info for simple for
simple dense sets it's very complicated
to understand the solarities and the
only that is the only thing you find it
in the right way that things Compact and
then you know um